having said that johnny
for the few people that don't know your
background can you take a quick minute
and tell everybody your background
my background your background admit it
yes
try to do it in a minute i mean you love
everybody you have you matter of fact
how about i do it for you here's what
i'm gonna do okay here's what i'm gonna
do when you and i did the the the show
together what was it three years three
that was three years ago i can't even
believe it's three years that's the last
time you guys saw each other sat in the
same room oh we've spoken i don't know
how i talk to them all wait we yeah
correspond yeah electronically but in
person in the person's three years ago
in my living room in new york how good
does he look he looks better today than
it was three years ago i'm not even
kidding with you first thing i said is i
can't believe how you look yeah he looks
better today than the three if you go
look at the podcast he looks better
today than three years probably what's
your secret johnny here we go i'm doing
stem cells man oh really doing stem
cells i'm part of an experiment my
second experiment my first was 1949 with
jonas salt for the salt vaccine for
polio
and then i got involved in this
in a very strange way
i was rushed to new york presbyterian
about 12 years ago
and
for six gunshots
and hold on what do you mean you were i
was shot six times at close range
anyway a friend
a friend of the family shot you okay and
when they went in to do it
they saw that my left side of my body
was smaller than my right side not
realizing my my five years of polio
and the doctors that were operating on
me
realized i'm a great candidate
for
having this stem cell how old were you
at the time
um
71 so no no 69 69 years old yeah i'll be
i'll be 80 this decision so what year
was that the first time you did it
did you hear what you just said folks
he'll be 80 this december 80. hey man
back to you let me get some money
by the way show that david can you show
that to see what he looks like there
versus what he looks like today
just show that picture
you look better today than you did in
that picture okay tanner healthier still
bling-bling and that's that's nice
all this has a meaning yeah everything
here everything i wear
is a meaning and not i just don't go to
the store so i like that buy it this is
a pin from my grandfather knights of
malta the vatican wow i mean all this
stuff needs something what's the most
meaningful piece of jewelry you're
rocking uh john paul
who's now a saint he gave me
the crest that's covered right now
because a solidarity to ukraine
covered it with a black ribbon but he
gave me that 1948
you're talking about the pope pope john
paul who's now a saint yeah which and my
little kids my grandkids say to me papa
you're the only guy we know you really
know is saying you knew him
19 to 40. because they all have pitches
yeah 1948. i was 48. oh you were 48.
okay you were 40 when he gave it to and
you met him over there yeah was he was
vatican
i was there for the i knew three popes
two pride of him the one that had the
short run
and then they inaugurated him and i was
part of that i was very good friends
with uh bishop marsinkas
during the vatican and the man the
vatican bank and
we were doing a lot of business out of
vegas for about 20 years with him so if
you enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]